[Music]
hour number two of the program tuesday
edition
august the 7th 2018 we're two days away
from week one of the preseason and i
just did that to see if stats would kick
in his pavlovian response and pump his
fists and there he goes the bell rings
and fido begins to salivate because it's
time to eat what kind of response was
that what what are you talking about pat
pablo
pavlovian texas education yes yes i'm
still not sure what that is so don't
worry
says the west virginia education guy all
right
let's get right to it odell beckham jr
still trying to get a new contract with
the
new york giants he spoke to reporters
over the weekend let's let me play that
sound now because i got so caught up in
the discussion last hour i forgot to
actually call for the sound so here's
beckham let's set the stage for this as
to what beckham wants on saturday he was
asked if he still hopes to be the
highest paid receiver in football here's
what he said
of course i mean who doesn't want to
get more money you know everybody does
so
realistically you know you got to be
realistic with yourself you see you see
what happened over the off-season
i can't really worry about anybody else
just let them figure it out and whenever
it happens it'll happen
okay here's the thing
the reporting began to emerge yesterday
suggesting there is some
controversy between the giants and
beckham and as it initially came out
chris josina anderson of espn.com
reported the giants are offering beckham
less than what sammy watkins got sammy
watkins got 16 million a year from the
chiefs on the open market earlier this
season then later in the day nfl media
partially owned by the giants reported
the giants have already offered to make
beckham the highest paid player in
football here's what it is in a nutshell
it all comes down to how you look at the
dollars and typically what happens after
a contract is done the agents will leak
the numbers to reporters by using what
they call the new money analysis where
you only look at the new years of the
deal because if you only look at the new
years of the deal the deal looks better
when you divide it by the total value
the length of the deal it comes out to
in this case
17.1 million that's the magic number
that's how you get north of antonio
brown he's at 17. so you do a five-year
deal worth 17.1 million per year hey
you're the highest paid receiver in
football
in this case what happened is the agent
ahead of time instead of looking at new
money the agent is focusing on total
value putting in the money that beckham
is due to make this year eight and a
half million and running the average and
lo and behold if you consider what he's
making this year he's south of sami
watkins so the conflicting reports that
came out yesterday that espn says it's
under sammy watkins 16 million
the the nfl media reporters say it's
above brown's 17 million average it all
comes down to this new money analysis
and here's the bottom line
right now they're in they're in one
ballpark that ballpark of taking antonio
brown's deal and doing a little bit
better the bigger question chris and i
want you to answer this for me is
beckham so much better than the other
great receivers in the game that he we
shouldn't be having this discussion of
splitting hairs and how much more is he
making relative to antonio brown should
he be so much higher than everyone else
i'm not going to say he should be so
much higher than everybody else i do
think that
there's there should be a significant
bump in what he makes as compared to
antonio brown i just think about where
he's at in his career the type of
athlete he is he's just about to really
hit the prime of his career right now uh
as an nfl football player and a receiver
and really becoming nuanced and things
like that uh so yes i do think odell
beckham jr deserves to be paid uh more
than antonio brown listen i'm not gonna
of course more am i gonna say
significantly more no but we saw
somebody like uh kirk cousins sign a
contract and get what 27 million a year
basically and then 20 28 and then matt
ryan came by and got 30 right i i would
i would think that's fair for odell
beckham jr here 19 million a year type
of average i think he's that type of
player you keep him happy he's got the
record holder is the highest paid wide
receiver and really mike you and i know
really at the end of the day
for the most part it's going to be about
the guaranteed money he sees unless he
signs like a four-year deal then it
might not matter as much but it's really
going to be about the guaranteed money
and the amount of money he can see in
the first three years of that contract
that's really what it all comes down to
well you're right and and they haven't
even gotten to that part right as the
reports come out i mean i think this
comes down to the value of a five-year
extension i i did the math you take that
five-year extension at 17.1
and yes highest paid receiver in
football but you throw on what he's due
to make this year it becomes 15.6 not
acceptable not acceptable and the irony
here is the agent
before the deal is done is focused on
this total value calculation which the
agent never wants us to do it's after
the fact oh no it's new money only look
at the new money no you don't look at
the new money because it's one big deal
and you have to look at what the total
value is at signing and the team for a
change is pushing this new money
analysis so this is all being turned on
its head as the two sides try to squeeze
each other into doing the deal and the
bottom line is this chris if odell
beckham jr really wanted to set a new
bar so much higher than what anyone else
is making he should have done the one
thing that you and i advocated a year
ago right he should have held out the
same way aaron donald is holding out the
same way khalil mack is holding out now
it's not getting those guys their
contracts yet but it's a lot harder if
you want to get a transcendent contract
because you believe you're a
transcendent player you've got to stay
away you've got to withhold services
because what are the giants losing here
what are they facing you're right they
still have him in camp yeah you're the
only threat they're facing right now is
the fact that they have to talk about
this and they have to hear about it on
talk radio and they might have to have
public uh backlash when
people like myself who root for the
giants and nobel beckham jr hear reports
that he's gonna get paid less than sammy
watkins you're gonna get public backlash
sorry for a guy like for a guy like
odell beckham jr who you know i want to
remind people is the fastest to 250
receptions in the career in the history
of the nfl he's the fastest of 4 000
yards in the history of the nfl he's the
most games with 125 plus yards in the
first three seasons the guy is on pace
and the injury of course last year threw
him off a little bit but he was on he's
on pace to be first ballot hall of famer
type of talent type of guy now getting
back to what you said
taking away his leverage and playing
business i'll i'll go back to what we
talked about to start the show right
with john mara and the giants being in
the football business
i you know i'm mad at odell beckham jr
because yes i do think he should have
sat out and played hardball
but he knows the maras he knows the
giants
he's also knows that he's done a few
things that hasn't got them in and their
good fit or got himself in their good
favor
and he's playing business the giant way
which is i'm gonna change my perception
publicly here in the tri-state area in
the new york area and i'm gonna be
johnny professional for the mara family
who's you know owned the giants since
the 1920s and he's putting that foot
forward and it sounds like to this point
at least progress is being made i mean
we're not going to say he did the right
thing until he gets the big deal
but for the most part i do think he's
changed his perception up here in the
new york area and i do think he's got
things going in the right direction
yeah and i agree with that completely
and the bottom line is that it's in the
giants long-term interest to get this
done however
the big
the big business reality for these teams
whether it's the giants and beckham the
raiders in mac the rams and donald the
key is what we could do
this year next year the year after that
versus the kind of money that the player
wants and i think that's precisely why
these deals aren't done because the
teams recognize that we have rights
right now this goes to aaron rodgers as
well sure the packers look at they've
got him under contract for two more
years they could tag him for two years
after that i've done the math already
there they could keep him for less than
25 million a year for the next four
years so so
why trade that in right in a sport where
that serious injury is lurking around
every corner why in the world trade in
the rights you currently have for some
huge windfall that you're not required
to give especially because
none of these guys well i can't say none
because donald and mack are away and who
knows when they're going to be back but
beckham's in camp rogers is in camp why
should we do anything and i think that
that and i think what happens chris and
this gets back to why you and i believe
that players should always take a stand
and get as much as they can when they
can because they only have one or two
chances for their career that's right
the teams are dealing with this all the
time that this is what the teams do
they've been in business the giants have
been in business for 100 years they've
dealt with players after players after
players thousands of players tens of
thousands of players they're not going
to get emotional about any one of these
players and that makes it easier to make
a dispassionate business decision and
that's the disconnect here and the
giants i think believe it's sufficient
to say hey we'll we'll make you the
highest paid receiver in football that's
what you want here's your 17.1 on a new
money analysis and that should be good
enough and i i credit the agent
for
because it's clear the agent's feeding
this information to espn right for for
turning the new money analysis on its
head and saying no this is really a deal
that's only worth 15.6 million and
that's not acceptable and this guy is so
much better that we shouldn't be
worrying about beating antonio brown by
just a little bit we should give this
guy the money that that reflects his
overall value to the game the problem is
the giants can say we'll just go year to
year and by the time he's able to hit
the open market saquon barkley would be
the face of the franchise not otto
beckham jr yeah i mean you're right it
could be that way i i i'll argue it in
this in this fact i mean first of all
yes as we talked about for odell beckham
jr to receive an offer
uh i don't care with how you play with
the numbers that's less than a brandon
cooks or a sami watkins or deandre
hopkins or mike evans is i mean outright
disrespectful to odell beckham jr so i
sure the hell hope he doesn't take
anything like that
the other thing i'll say is where i do
think he has a little
leverage here with the giants and he it
it's the giants working against the
giants a little bit but the giants are
professional organization like we've
talked about the mara's the tish's they
want to do they want to do good uh by
their football players but i think they
also realize that they have a talented
team with a quarterback who is on his
last leg i mean this is the last year or
two of the eli manning era and for them
to say okay we're going to make a
distraction with our best player and our
team and not have him signed and make
this media spectacle and oh yeah man our
quarterback who's on his last leg he's
only actually very good when odell is in
there
so how much of a distraction is it
really for the giants he's in camp yes
right who cares if there are there's
always going to be stories about the
giants it's got to be something so who
cares if the stories about whether he's
been offered 17.1 million or 15.6
million that's nothing compared to what
what it could be so okay we'll deal with
the distraction we'll keep our money in
our pocket and we'll just play this out
instead of giving the guy you know the
20 million a year contract that he seems
to want yeah well it's early right now
let's wait till we get a little back
later here in the preseason and training
camp and if we're still having the same
conversation about 16 million it's gonna
become a distraction and i'll tell you
this is where i think the other area
it'll affect the giants it's gonna
filter into the locker room the locker
room's gonna look at management and look
at the owners and go damn this guy has
been a baller for your football team and
you guys have really only been in
existence and and relevant the last few
years because of this guy and you're not
going to reward him and then he took the
risk of coming to training camp on a
lame duck one year 8.5 million deal is
the best receiver in football that's
what the giants will have to worry about
because other guys in the locker room
are going to start to speak out and
start to be disgruntled about it and
then it's beginning to become a
distraction a conversation in the locker
room even when the media is not there
do you really think that the locker room
at large is going to coalesce and rally
around the poor mistreated odell beckham
jr i don't see that happening and i
think this gets back to all of his annex
from the last few years i i don't i look
i don't know the dynamics of that locker
room but i think human nature would tell
me that there isn't going to be a you
know a bake sale slash pity party for
odell beckham jr in that locker room
because he i mean he he's created plenty
of distractions for that team on his own
uh yes he has i i get that and really
the oh the biggest distraction is the
boat trip okay let's just say that he
went off he went he went to miami in a
day off and it wasn't the best look
during the week a wild card playoff game
and he dropped a few balls to start that
game and that's really where it started
from he's not been that bad overall for
the most part i mean yeah he proposed to
a kicking net he threw a right jab at a
kicking net oh my gosh that's so
horrible what a bad guy but everything i
know mike is that the locker room loves
odell beckham jr and the people within
the giants organization love odell
beckham jr so you're right i'm not
trying to sit here and say that the guys
in the in the locker room are gonna like
create a mutiny and start marching up
the stairs to the mirror to the mara
office and being like you better pay
this guy and they getting their pitch
forks out and you know uh and getting
mad at them no but i do think that the
players will start to start to fuel the
public fire of perception about that hey
they need to pay this guy it's
ridiculous how awesome he's been and he
hasn't done this and then that's going
to fuel the talk radio here in new york
and then it becomes a huge spectacle and
that's where i say
i don't think it will be i don't think
it will be because as games get played
especially regular season games get
played the vacuum gets filled by talking
about what the team is doing and these
contractual niceties end up fading
toward the edge of the radar screen
that's what i believe and i also believe
we get to get games right take a break
we gotta take a break all right we gotta
take a break